oh man check this out dog take this out
look at this fine piece of ass all the
way down the street here dog talking
about this hey girl yeah walk this way
with that fine ass so flip yeah girl
won't you come down here and put that in
my mouth cause daddy want a snack blap
why are you hurting me girl
hurting me friskity
just that's deliciousness yeah
yeah
yeah keep it coming ye
and and that is a professional
basketball mascot that is a man
in an orange rhinoceros costume
hello
[Music]
miss clarissa i'm gonna tell you girl in
that dress you looking about as sweet as
a field full of honeysuckle after a
spring rain shower
how do you do it girl
bad ass no
[Music]
what was that what was what what you
just said to her oh
i was just following your lead no you
wasn't you was being all heavy-handed
with it man you got to be subtle
subtle exactly you to be subtle you want
to talk to them ladies i can do that
[Music]
mr niece
you're the way that dresses flowing you
look like a mountain creek after the
spring thaw simply refreshing
what is your
secret way that dress fitting on you got
them
titties popping out
what amazing what
here
yo
secret what did you do what are you
doing
i was just doing what you were doing no
you wasn't i even said what if your
secret that's what abatem that part was
did you hear me saying anything about
anybody's titties
no you know what
how about we just say no words all
together no words all together
question yeah how will i talk you're not
gonna talk okay all right
ladies i'm sorry y'all hurt my eye y'all
just like smoldering like the sun
and just as bright and then beautiful
dressing mm-hmm
[Music]
vagina
what the hell was that oh i just said
word at the end there didn't i did you
see the part where oh this was going on
and shaking the tail feathers and
whatnot i didn't see it i got the worst
view in the house
that's what chased them away man all
right you know what
stay away from me all right
miss laverne
you
like a long stemmed rose the way you
looking and smelling
what is your recipe
damn boy
i bet you got a big old digging ball
i love you
[Music]
oh man i really had to get out of the
house i'm just glad you came out i
appreciate it for real
i'm gonna go check this girl out man she
is fine
she i
really hey man i am going to go to the
bathroom okay man let's see in a minute
you know what i told myself this morning
i wasn't gonna fall in love
you went and made me break my only rule
i'm gonna take that right quick i am
going to take that i'm going to use that
okay
oh hey what's up man
got her number huh yeah cheyenne oh was
that her name yeah she was fly that
that's that's the girl i was talking
about
oh snap are you serious yeah dude oh i'm
sorry ain't no thing but forgive me
there's plenty of eyes here i just let
you stop talking about
i'm not a sports man but
i think me and you could touch down
later if you know what i'm saying
am i being stupid but for real though
just give me your number whatever
thank you girl i'm gonna take that from
you
how did you get over here so fast
nothing it just seemed like you the
death toll is seven damn second day that
reporter is smoking hot
[Music]
no
no
no
[Music]
no
no hey baby
how are you
are you doing that honey what's wrong
baby i love you
i'm sorry i was out i was looking at
other women tonight
but you are all there is
i love you
jihad my friend
there are a lot of beautiful women out
here today
kareem my friend you speak the truth i
do what i can
oh
wow right
blimps
you know what i caught a little glimpse
of her foot nuts
you saw ankle bone yeah you got some
anchor cleavage
huh
[Music]
[Applause]
did you see the bridge on that nose i
mean if it is any indication
holy garbanzo beans there is a bridge
i'd like to cross
this is my boy this is my boy this is my
boy
not allowed to go on not really not
really good height good height good
height crazy tall like five
nine
huh
come on yeah come on come on
she's done that's right she's thirsty
can i tell you something and confidence
right now
i'm a virgin
[Music]
oh
every american woman is more infidel
than the last you're telling me
[Music]
okay come on full frontal face
only in america baby
in america
what did you see
this is yours and then that is yours
what did you see
we've got the exit
would you look at the leg elbows on that
one
what i wouldn't do for a six
seconds with her yes
what did you do
right now
[Laughter]
button
that's belly button my friend i couldn't
believe it but i've never seen the belly
button on a woman before i thought it
was a me yes it's like the
butthole of the belly
oh
yes
homosexual and american devils give them
the whistle of disapproval i will right
now
that is my boy that should teach them
here is your white wine thank you you
are welcome hey pete
a little uh a little thirsty tonight ah
yeah
super thirsty
pete this is erasa all right so this is
uh pete theresa just got back from
africa oh
africa
uh anyways uh where was i oh the auc oh
right so this conflict is exactly the
reason that the african union commission
was put in place to address the
organization of african unity certainly
wasn't going to do anything exactly and
if in costa zana la minizuma wants to do
anything about bangui she's certainly
being quiet about it the worst part
about bunkie is that no one knows what's
going on oh no
look at right next door the south sudan
here's the thing everybody just thinks
that it's like it's the damn lion king
over there you know lion king
excuse me
it's not the lion king
exactly i mean what do people think
a
baboon is gonna hold a lion cub
over a rock up to the sun while all the
little animals sing
[Music]
um something else i wanted to mention is
they have the manpower because amisom
has 25 000 troops just sitting there in
somalia it's not a three
animated hyena situation that doesn't
make any sense the bad guy isn't scar
over there
um
yeah yeah that's right it's not like
scar's the bad guy huh well i mean you
know the truth is no one knows who to
blame because in reality amazon doesn't
have that much control
i don't like simba
oh like simba he had no control
over
he was plucked out
from his home and went on a whole
journey before he came back and was just
in the middle of a war
really had nothing to do with him you
know pete i'd be really interested in
hearing your thoughts on the un's
policies in east africa
[Music]
hakuna matata
unbelievable
yes
oh my god that sums it up perfectly
there's so much work still to be done
yes that's what i was saying it's been
going on for so many years so many years
circle of life
exactly that's really brilliant
talking about brilliant let's dial it
back
i'm just a man okay uh i'm gonna i'm
gonna go get some uh
some more derps okay no need to announce
it
[Music]
what are your thoughts on the middle
east
aladdin
[Music]
he's just